[Applause]
then store our auto present era pretty
staggerin of spurious Riksbank freeze
economic reactance cough till alfred
nobel's Midna it is a great honor to
introduce the laureate of this various
Riksbank prize in Economic Sciences in
memory of Alfred Nobel Professor Richard
Taylor
[Applause]
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
excellencies dear laureates ladies and
gentlemen I had to run back because I
decided we had a deficiency of toasts so
I will end this with a toast I'm truly
truly humbled to be standing here today
my feelings of humility are accentuated
by the invidious comparisons with my
fellow laureates their discoveries of
colliding black holes genes that know
the time of day and images of
biomolecules using cryo-electron
microscopy are rather daunting and what
about the beautiful speech Kazuo
Ishiguro's just gave breaking a one-year
tradition he managed to win the
Literature Prize without a single hit
song
so what did I do to get up here I
discovered the presence of human life in
a place not far far away
where my fellow economists thought it
did not exist the economy instead of
humans the world by describe described
by economists in textbooks is populated
by a species referred to as Homo
economicus but I like to just call them
econ's these econ solve problems like a
supercomputer have the willpower of
saints our free of emotion and have
little regard for their fellow econ's
now the presence of humans in our
economy might seem rather obvious
customers and employees are human even
most CEOs are quite human furthermore
economists engage with humans on a
regular on a rather regular basis and
often find their behavior to be deeply
flawed indeed economists love telling
stories that ridicule the flawed
decision making made by others such as
their spouses offspring Dean's students
political leaders and please keep this
part to yourself one even hear stories
criticizing the decision making made by
the esteemed members of the economics
Nobel Prize Committee
so a lot of laughter over there so we
have a disconnect between the people
economists know and the econ's that
appear in their theories over the past
40 years along with many colleagues some
of whom are here I've been trying to
figure out how to introduce humans into
economic theory we humans are
absent-minded tend to be a little
overweight we procrastinate and are
notoriously overconfident to be sure we
still need traditional economic theories
but to make accurate predictions we need
to enrich those theories by adding
insights from other social sciences
incorporating human behavior into
economic models improves the accuracy of
economics just as those fancy
microscopes improve the resolution of
images in biochemistry crucially once we
acknowledge that humans are fallible
creatures we can ask how to help them
make better decisions as Cass Sunstein
and I have argued we can often do so
with simple nudges that point people in
the right direction but don't force
anyone to do anything
we need these helpful nudges now more
than ever consider the most important
issues facing the world now such as
climate change health care an aging
population income inequality xenophobia
and mounting threats to world peace each
of these problems is at its heart
behavioral but in these times when all
news seems to be bad or fake
I can report on progress around the
world governments and NGOs are working
with behavioral scientists to design and
test scientifically informed policies
that are working people are being helped
to save more for retirement more poor
kids especially girls are going to
school peasant farmers are achieving
more reliable harvests and we're all
being successfully nudged to use less
energy so I'd like to end this with the
toast I promised using a phrase I write
when I'm asked to sign books that that
phrase which is meant as a plea is nudge
for good tonight we will modify that
phrase to honor Alfred Nobel so please
raise your glasses and join with me in a
toast in the proper Swedish manner of
course no clinking nudge for the
greatest benefit of mankind thank you
[Applause]